polycystic ovary syndrome
also called psc is an imbalance
of female sex hormones the
ovaries are part of the
female reproductive system along with the
fallopian tubes
the uterus
and vagina
your ovaries contain your eggs
these eggs are immature and are
stored in small structures  you have
this fluid called follicles
the pituitary gland at the
base of your brain produces hormones that
direct the function of your ovaries
each month the pituitary gland
secretes follicle-stimulating hormone or
efe sh and luteinizing hormone lh
into your bloodstream
after you are  hormones reach
the ovaries several hundred
immature eggs begin to mature
increasing in size of the
follicles as the eggs mature the
follicles secrete estrogen the
main female sex hormone
once the amount of estrogen in the
blood reaches a certain level
the pituitary  send a lot of  e
luteinizing hormone to the ovaries
causing the more mature follicle to
open and release its egg in a process
called ovulation
the released egg travels down the
fallopian tube where it awaits fertilization
over time the immature follicles and
remaining eggs dissolve
if the  the egg is not fertilized the egg and
the lining of the uterus is shed
during the next menstrual period
if you have polycystic ovary
syndrome your pituitary gland
may release abnormally high amounts
of luteinizing hormone into your
bloodstream which disrupts your
normal menstrual cycle as a result
the follicles do not mature and ovulation
does not occur which can lead to
infertility some of the
immature follicles do not dissolve and remain
as fluid filled sacs or cysts
also the doctor may find that your
blood has high levels of insulin
a hormone produced by  the
pancreas excess insulin in combination c
High levels of luteinizing hormone
can lead to excess production
of a male hormone called
testosterone in the ovaries
Abnormally high levels of testosterone
stop ovulation which can
lead to
infertility High levels of testosterone
also cause many of the
physical characteristics  associated with
polycystic ovary syndrome such
as acne and abnormal hair growth
having polycystic ovary
syndrome increases the risk of
type 2 diabetes due to excess
insulin and insulin resistance
heart disease high
blood pressure
cholesterol abnormalities in  blood
and endometrial cancer
since there is no cure for
polycystic ovary syndrome, the doctor may
recommend one or more medications to
treat its symptoms such as
hormonal contraceptives that apart from
preventing pregnancy also regulate the
menstrual cycle and reduce the production
of  testosterone and  n the
ovaries antiandrogenic drugs that
reduce abnormal hair growth
and acne diabetes drugs
such as meth morphine that lower
insulin levels and regulate the
cycle
and fertility drugs
that stimulate ovulation so there
may be  pregnant
if you want to get pregnant and
fertility drugs have not
been successful in
restoring ovulation your doctor may recommend
laparoscopic ovarian incision
during the procedure
your surgeon will insert a small needle
into your ovary and use an
electrical current to destroy the tiny
areas of ovarian tissue where testosterone is produced
over time testosterone production
decreases and ovulation may occur